bonjour et bienvenue sur rhodia gonal tv
pour ce championnat du monde féminin
2016 on va voir aujourd'hui donc cette
huitième 8e partie avec donc déjà une
partie maintenant décisive
une victoire 2 ou lifan dans cette
partie et le match est terminé plier
puisqu'il ne restera que deux parties
être points de retard et en cas de
parties nulles on peut dire aussi que le
championnat sera très certainement enfin
1 99% plier aussi puisque vous gagnez
deux parties de suite sur commande comme
ça c'est ça serait du jamais vu pourquoi
pas bon mais c'est jamais sûr mais ça
paraît extrêmement improbable mais alors
maria mozy tout cas quand même les
blancs donc elle peut dans cette partie
pourquoi pas donc réussir l'exploit qui
mettrait la pression sur son adversaire
pour les deux dernières parties mais il
faudrait vraiment gagner cette partie
donc partie vraiment importante et
décisive pour ce championnat du monde
avec pour mariam ou zid foot le premier
coup des quatre voilà donc là elle varie
elle revient un coup pions dame et le
rendre revient pas dans les coûts du
pion roi donc on a une partie variés
dans ce championnat cabaye m6 kalyev 3e
6 et g3 voilà donc alors on a une
catalane quand quand les blancs jouent
comme ça avec le pion dames et g3 et que
les noirs ne font pas eux-mêmes j'ai six
coups g7
ce qui serait une variante de la deûle
et indienne voilà on appelle ça en
général le catalan
peu importe à la limite c'est pas très
important des 5 fu g2elab et 5 ou coup
intéressant on profite du fait que le
fou se développe ici sur cette grande
diagonale pour jouer b5 et aussi le fou
et un f1 c'est plus délicat puisque ce
pion serait tout de suite sous l'
attaque du fou si on avait joué trois
mais si on n'aurait pas pu et donc voilà
c'est justifié par le fait que le foot
le côté donc on essaie on en profite en
quelque sorte pour
essayer de gagner l'espace petit rock
par la poupée 7 en plus permet de jouer
bon ceci dit hors des camps il tape sur
son propre opinion
mais c'est un but important au centre
qui contrôle la case 2,4 notamment donc
bon on peut pas dire non plus que ce fou
et inutile a mis des millions qu'il est
extrêmement actif dans le camp adverse
mais il est extrêmement puissant en
termes de mesures de contrôle du centre
à 4 alors voilà donc à quatre c'est
important parce que il faut créer des
ruptures si on veut c'est d'avoir
davantage aux échecs c'est souvent le
cas une rupture une rupture c'est quoi
c'est le fait justement de pouvoir
briser des chaînes de pions avec les
pions donc ici à quatre on veut forcer
ce pion à bouger afin de jouer plus tard
ces quatre noms ne peut jamais joué ses
4,6 en fonction si on fait pas bouger ce
pion parce que ces quatre c'est l'idée
des blancs alors faudrait jouer b3 c4
sera envisageable bien sûr mais c'est
une autre idée et c4 pour essayer bien
tôt ou tard de d'échangés au centre et
d'ouvrir les lignes voilà ça ouvre la
colonne c'est ici vous ouvrir cette
colonne
on veut affaiblir un peu le centre
pourquoi pas si on élimine un pion
central
plus tard on pourrait envisager une
poussée comme eux quatre bon c'est
délicat parce que les noirs contrôle
très très bien le 4 mai il faudra jouer
peut-être f3c le cd très long terme tout
serein mais bon surtout c'est l'idée
c'est d'ouvrir cette colonne c'est de
faire une petite pression centre est
pour ça donc il faut il faut créer la
pression ici sur les cases blanches il
faut éliminer ce défenseur de ces quatre
donc les noirs d'ailleurs le pousse
plutôt que le défendre à noter que c'est
très difficile à défendre parce qu'un
coup comme à six est possible mais dans
ce cas là on perd mais puis on prend
puis on prend tout reprend le couvent à
huit est sans doute ce pion bessengue
pas toujours pouvoir être attaqué par
des coups comme cavalier à 3 calais ces
trois voire même dame détroit et comment
on défend si on défend avec le pion sait
s'ils sont bouche encore plus le fou
bessette et ça paraît pas être une bonne
idée on se relève d'une case aussi pour
le cavalier là mais je pense qu'avec ce
soit eu envie de sortir 17 bon bref donc
les noirs jouent b4 cela pose pas de
problème a priori ils ont ils ont un
pion b4 qui est aussi un peu pénible il
quand même en comblant contre la casse
et 3 à 3 il est protégé par le fouet
suite est plus tard son copain à sète va
sans doute venir en scène pour se
protéger mais on affaiblit un peu les
caisses blanche
voilà donc déjà c4 un peu moins bien
protégée messins qui est faible c'est
une casse faible un petit peu on peut
toujours avec les pions c'est le bouger
mais sûr mais ça enfin le fou voilà donc
on est on affaiblit un peu de ce côté là
de façon à pouvoir avancer
ces quatre tout de suite alors ça c'est
intéressant on n'a pas peur de la prise
en passant puisque certainement
reprendre et du pion b et on poussera
quand même ces 4es du coup les noirs ont
joué ce pion pour rien puisqu'il y aura
avancé et au final il n'existe plus donc
on aura perdu des temps très
certainement et c'est pas une bonne idée
donc les noirs ne prennent pas et
consolident b4 et maintenant vous voulez
c'est alors fou et s'inquiète un coup
logique ici mais sur sakho cavaliers bon
c'est jamais mauvais en soi mais surtout
sa jour contre le centre parce que ce
cavalier défend les cases blanches au
centre à la fois des 5,4 donc on n'aura
pas peur d'échangés sous contre le
cavalier parce que ça augmente aura
notre contrôle des cases blanches au
centre et donc ça ajoutera du potentiel
à une future poussée de quatre là ça
deviendra d'actualité c'est plus défendu
que par le point 4 et le fou su faire
admettre le cai en d2 la tour 1 et boum
on pourra mettre de quatre câbles et b17
pour les noirs voiliers et on se presse
pas date de questionner le fou parages 6
on sort d'un banc lecavalier peut-être
plus tard le forage 6 et en cas de
prisons reprenant du cavalier ce qui
fait qu'on voyait que c'est harmonieux
cali les deux il faut 7
tours c'est un se pressent pas joli tour
c'est l'un des biens très bien ce début
dans l'optique de prendre le jour en d5
la colonne c'est voir avec le pion c7 en
ligne de mire au lundi 6 h 6 voilà la
seule heure pour les noirs de
questionner le faut évidemment prendre
le fou n'a pas de case 1 parce que s'il
prend pas aussi bien h katia g5 qui perd
le fou si on revient ici oui basse ou g5
par le fou henri iv peut-être on peut
juger scène quand même une fou est
obligé d'aller ou en 3 certainement et
dans ce cas là qu'avaient les g4 et le
fou sera pris avec en plus un doublement
de pions ce qui serait pas bon du tout
donc n'a pas le choix en fait il faut
prendre mais bon c'était l'idée des
blancs n'y a pas de problème et la foux
prend donc ça c'est intéressant
elle prend pas du cavalier qui aurait
augmenté la pression sur quasiment elle
prend plutôt du fou qui met une petite
pression sur le pion des quatre bons
moi pas alors à noter aussi que le
cavalier là peut aider à une future
poussée ses cinq co les noirs ont envie
de faire un maximum des changes au
centre ces cinq dans ce cas là en cas de
prise bay se fout attaquerez aussi des
deux des idées simples dames ces deux
voiliers dans la dame ces 2 bat déjà ça
prouve que ça contre le b2 donc dans
cette optique là on pourrait prendre
sans craindre de perdre les deux et puis
ça rajoute de la pression sur la colonne
s'est notamment bien le pion c7 la série
en même temps ça fait quelque chose
d'assez important pour finir un
développement en général salih les tours
cela fait maintenant sept tours peut
venir au centre par exemple à noter
aussi que la dame en plus contrôler la
case e 4 qui nous aide bien pour pousser
le pion et donc créer une rupture au
centre forcer les noirs à prendre et
donc à ouvrir le jeu
ce que les blancs envie de faire
puisqu'ils sont mieux placés au centre
ils ont un peu d'avancé du à l'ouverture
donc ce coup de damer est magnifique un
sale c'est sans doute la meilleure case
de la dame sur tout l'échiquier c2c
contre erdf et tous à un contrôle à la
fois donc un petit oeil sur sur quatre
un petit oeil sur b2 et un petit oeil
sur ces 7 alors
si un petit oeil sur ces 7 elle est
parfaite alors c'est parti c'est 6 donc
la c6 belge empêche la prison c'est 7
je compte des 5 c'est comme un cookie
par un peu poussif 1 parce que le foot
est lui par contre il est complètement
bouché mais sans doute les noirs envie
de le jouer à 6 de toute façon où il a
une belle diagonale assez intéressant
c'est donald toujours là regardez ya
plein de choses à ramasser et à des
cases à affaiblir maman il est pas si
mal en 6 e 4 ça y est c'est l'heure donc
là le coup d'autant plus fort que le
football est donc ya pas de double
contrôle henri iv et la bombe
4 on peut envisager maintenant pleine
prise au centre on peut envisager de
pousser pour chasser le fou bon voilà
les blancs sont bien au centre n'y a pas
de problème ça se voit à l'oeil un petit
rock et noir ne craignent pas c'est vrai
que d'un côté leurs pions des cinq
extrêmement bien défendu c'est si ceux
ci sous bessette c'est extrêmement
solide ils attendent de voir ce que
veulent faire les blancs la position
étant solide et bien les blancs jouent
aux 5
alors pourquoi pas le foot nous inoculer
et maintenant où un peu surprenant à
première vue pour ces cinq donc lâche
abandonner l'idée de rupture alors à
première vue cela peut être surprenant
d'un point de vue stratégique que ça
général il faut noter que c'est les
noirs qu'on la perd de fou et la paire
de fouet d'autant plus puissante que le
jeu est ouvert
alors parce que c'est les pièces à
longue portée qui aiment avoir des
diagonales bon et voyez bien que la
ici-bas soffrina qu'une diagonale bon
ceci dit elle est pas mal mais il va pas
pouvoir se faire aider c'est à dire qu'
il va contrôler des cases mais tout seul
s'il fait que bon tout seul ça risque
est un peu léger ça c'est un premier
point et deuxièmement ce fou pour
l'instant lui il n'a pas de jeu en fait
du tout dire que la housse et qui peut
aller banuls parent ya pas qu à bonal
pour lui on voit même même ans alors il
faudrait peut-être qu'ils jouent
même pas assis viande et 8 c'est cette
étape toujours contre mur il tape contre
des murs partout se fout donc l'idée
stratégique ici c'est de lire ben c'est
moi qui les deux cavaliers
en fait j'ai la paire de cavaillé si on
veut aussi sa part dans ce sens mais on
a quand même la paire de cavaillé contre
la paire de fou et dans les positions
resserrées comme celle ci car ils sont
plus forts et c'est vrai et c'est ce
qu'on va voir dans cette partie
justement g5 pour les noirs alors j'ai
cinq sans doute pour éviter de un
étouffement parce que les blancs menaces
et peut-être de jouer eux mêmes h4 et là
ça devient plus difficile puisque en cas
de h katia puis on prend et il ya
combien fouet dame s'est perdu donc si
les blancs avaient joué h 4 on n'aurait
jamais pu jouer g5 on aurait enlevé
encore descazeaux fou et on aurait pu
monter une attaque de cavaliers un base
de cas alliage de cavaler g4 qui tape
sur h6 l'autre cavalli qui va venir soit
par f3 son joug tour ou un parent f1 la
dame qui va venir on va recommencer à
menacer des sacrifices et ça risque de
vite devenir pénible ça a l'air de rien
comme ça c'est lent mais c'est une
position resserré et ce genre de plan ça
marche assez bien en général
donc j'ai sexe pour empêcher ce type de
manoeuvre à long terme donc c'est bien
joué h323 sans doute pour deux raisons
hop
j'empêche g4 qui aurait pu être
intéressant pourquoi pas mais j'ai 4 il
aurait fallu jouer après h5 pour
protéger g4 ça me paraît assez faible
qu'en et ses pions la liste aurait été
dangereux mais l'autre idée c'est qu'un
jour je crois je peux jouer cavaye age 2
et venir au g4 et l'âge affaibli justice
et si je joue oblige les blés noirs
ajout espions alors là là le roi devient
faible et on peut envisager des poussées
par f4 ensuite des choses comme ça avec
avec une grosse attaque
c'est tout à fait tout à fait
envisageable donc ici 3g cette logique
on met le roi un petit peu proche de son
petit pion femme lâche 6 et puis on
envisage en cas de au cas où ça chauffe
de jouer tourache fuite
voilà pour empêcher trop de manoeuvre
peut-être aussi deux roues lors de jouer
tout j'ai vite entourage suite et le
cavalier aussi peuvent venir en fuite
puis j'ai six mois il se trouve un peu
de jeu voyez que c'est les cavaliers
d'ailleurs toujours pareil qui peuvent
trouver des cases 1 alors que les foules
1 pour l'instant ils sont un peu mieux
et toi tôt 1
l'idée très certainement c'est pas
tellement bon de protéger eux s'est même
si bien sûr c'est toujours bien de
protéger encore plus un pion mais est
déjà protégée comme il faut mais bon
c'est bien aussi mais ceci dit c'est
surtout sans doute pour donner à caser
flanc cavaliers sq avait aussi envie de
venir en f1 alors son âge 2 pour
mélanger 4,63 aussi voilà donc les
blancs se pressent pas remarqué dans ce
type positions opposées se presser tout
est bloqué tous âges suite voilà donc
c'est l'idée qu'on avait dit on vient
sur la colonnade on protège ce point un
peu sensibles notamment en prévision
donc avalé g4 avait des sacrifices en a
6 bat là il y aura pas de sacrifice
j'aime bien y'a pas de problème
c'est solide fouet f1
alors c'était loterie des taux ainsi que
ça libère le fou ce fouillis but ici sur
des cinq donc on a envie de le sortir
peut-être en d3 pourquoi pas après en b1
d'ailleurs si on arrive à le remettre en
b1 avec un coup comme un fou des trois
dames b3 fou bénin puis après quand la
dame revient mais tout de suite là une
petite batterie et même si ces contrôles
est belle le jour où c'est plus
contrôler un échec là ça peut ça peut
faire mal on va pas trop comment mais il
ya des sacrifices qu'ils peuvent se
faire qui dévie les pions qui protège on
fait un objet si souci la tour bouge
viennent d'un match 7
bon on n'y est pas et de l'autre idée
aussi c'est que si les noirs jouent fois
ci c'est ben voilà on échange très
certainement dame g8
bon bon coup de j'ai vite l'idée des
noirs sans doute c'est devenir h7 est de
proposer les charges de dames pascale
positions resserrées comme ça ce qui
fait peur au noir c'est la montée
progressive d'une attaque
à noter que
damas 7 serait contré par food et 3 mais
peut-être que les noirs veulent jouer
d'abord fou à 6 et journal cet après à
six qui échangent et se fout et après
jouer damas est pourquoi pas tour 3 3
alors
l'idée de tours 3 bon déjà c'est un
petit oeil sur b3 non s'en fout parce
qu'a priori jamais les événements vont
jouer les 3 donc tour 3
dans certaines positions six cavalli 20h
deux peut-être la tour peut venir h
trois ans à f3 peut-être aussi que en
cas de calèche de f4 qui ont préemption
prend la tour pourra venir en g3 faire
un échec
voyez donc c'est une façon d'activer la
tour parce que je prévois un moyen terme
de faire une ouverture de ce côté voilà
je fais un petit jeu contrôle aussi un
petit peu la case d3 en cas de deux fois
six n'y a rien du tout des contrôles des
trois sapeurs très intéressant mais bon
voilà donc on active la tour c'est ça
peut pas être mauvais coup ella rae
suite et koukal mêmes moyens donc là le
roi il dit bon ok j'ai compris que par
là ça pouvait être un peu chaud je mens
je m'enlève est assez les noirs qui mine
de rien deux pièces lourdes
face au roi on lui crie pas trop parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de pièces autour de
lui il ya des pions devant bon crème
parent mais bon c'est jamais de s'ouvrir
et puis peut se passer des trucs imprévu
faut faire attention quand même
hop cavalier e vous voyez stratégiques
en vendant une partie stratégique
cavaliers et 20 ici bon ben je libère le
pion f donc ça peut être l'idée de jouer
à quatre leur part tout de suite parce
qu'en cas de prise comme le pion g3 sera
cloué ça pose un souci mais bon sans
doute les blancs ont prévu déjà aussi de
bouger seront un soin en h2 soit en h1
et si en prévision de sa cavalière
est-ce qu'on veut jouer qu'à les
détroits peut-être mais calais détroit
bon après le café ya pas de case un
scénographe quatre contrôles etc
mais c'est possible qu'il y ait des 3
pouces 9,4 en cas de prise je reprends
du cavalier ce possible et c'est les
noirs t'attaques h5 isolant bon mais
j'ai compris tu veux tu veux préparer
quelque chose ici mais donc du coup je
me suis préparé pour l'iphone contre
attaque et voit la cage et deux autres
idées dans ce cas il aime prendre des
trois il ya pas être 4 mais on joue qui
a allégé de et là maintenant f4 et
d'actualité f4 et d'actualité en cas
prises pour prend soin du pion soigne du
cavalier pourquoi pas
la tour va pouvoir coulisser sur la
troisième attaque et la dame se remettre
sur la colonne f
les petites idées faut préparer un faux
calcul et l'émission soit huit voix la
samba qui tu veux aller sur la colonne f
belges hollandais avant même que tu le
fasses prophylactique roche 2 ben là
c'est l'heure pour enlever
bien sûr le vis-à-vis d'un droit qui est
toujours quand même
tout petit peu pénible et cavaliers
suite
alors ça c'est bien on l'avait dit tout
à l'heure aussi que c'était une des
idées pour le cavalier devenir angers 6
qui contrôle un petit peu cette case f4
qui est cruciale en cas de rupture voilà
toujours cette idée de rupture
à noter que en cas de non acceptation
des noirci et leurs joues g4 par exemple
pour éviter la l'ouverture les blancs
peut être joué h4 pour bloquer ici et il
aurait toujours la rupture f5 fcn qui
ouvre le jeu sur le colonel est là
maintenant bons fous detroit alors fou
des trois ça se joue contre lequel j'ai
six peut-être six recalés g6 j'ai pas
peur de donner un fou parce qu'en fait
encore une fois dans cette position je
valorise mais cavaliers contre les fous
parce qu'on est dans une position ferme
et voilà on aura vu tout dans ce
championnat du monde la paire de fou et
la supériorité des cavaliers dans les
positions fermes et donc faut six bombes
bien jouer au bon moment
le fou blanc n'a pas le choix il peut
pas s'échapper donc il sera échangé
contre ce fou et pourquoi les noirs font
ça parce qu'ils veulent jouer cavalier
ci s'ils veulent pas bien sûr ils ont
compris qu'il valait mieux garder leurs
cavaliers que leur fou et la f4 seller
les blancs maintenant ils vont quand
même bien sûr faux c'est quelque chose
il faut rappeler la position championnat
il faut que les blancs l'emportent pour
avoir des chances raisonnables disons
est de revenir au score
donc la partie vraiment une partie à
mort un celle-ci vous prend un fou dans
prend
et d'un match 7 alors on l'avait dit
aussi idée d'échangé la dame
bon alors est ce que les blancs vont
accepter les changes de dames sont pas
obligés pour il pourrait jouer un coup
ou pour garder un maximum de pièces sur
l'échiquier comme dame f1 qui sans doute
un bon coup d'un met fin à mes fins on
commence à mettre une pièce courte sur
la colonne f on prévoit de mettre la
tour en f3 et de jouer f5 avec ouverture
des lignes sur la colonne f
on peut tripler aussi puisque si on a la
tour en f3 à la dame en f1 on pourrait
jouer une manoeuvre tour alors papa tour
ces deux métaux un tour deux tours rev 2
c'est long mais comme les positions
fermes et même si c'est long ça passe on
t'aurait ferme quand même bon alors là
donc du coup les charges de damas alors
ça c'est pas si c'est bien joué de la
part de mario morisi musique zouk ici de
permettre l'échangé de dan d'empreintes
reprend il ya toujours une attaque sur
la colonne est qui a toujours la seule
rupture vraiment intéressante dans cette
position elle est du côté blanc f5 à
tout moment où voire même pions pranger
5 ouvre la colonne f on peut encore
doubler les tours bon garder les dames à
mon avis c'était mieux parce que imaginé
en plus la dame 1 f1 alors vraiment été
bien parce que la dame en f1 en
imaginant le triplement des détours
cette tour la bombe se serait mis sur la
peut-être sur la septième pour essayer
de contrôler un peu aussi la défense
mais en cas d'ouverture en plus cette
dame des fois elle pourrait venir à 6,6
et tour bouge si cette eau est obligé de
bouger pour la défense ces dames en plus
voilà avait des possibilités d'entrer
dans le camp noir de l'autre côté
bon
et parce qu'elle sait pas ce qui a été
choisi puis on prend et cavale et prend
alors ses papiers on prend alors est ce
que je pouvais faire pions prend ici
très certainement c'est une autre partie
elle aurait pu aussi faire tout reprend
tout reprend pour garder la tour sur la
colonne est fait et ce cavalier va se
développer ailleurs bon pourquoi pas
mais qu à l epr ans un bon coup il n'y a
pas de problème qu'elle les troyens bons
coups c'est c'est bien joué qu'à et g6
et la cale et b3 alors voilà ça c'est le
coup moi j'aime bien ce coup regardez
comme les blancs ont laissé leurs pions
en b2 ce pion à 4 et jamais attaquable
par les noirs le fouet sur cases noires
absurde et que sa sauce cavaliers mais
ce cavalier les trop occupé la défense
et voilà l'idée c'est qu'on a un petit
oeil sur le pion à 5 alors ça a l'air de
rien mais ça oblige les noirs à soit
gardé la torah 8 soit de jouer le front
des 8es à bloquer leurs fous voilà donc
ça ça immobilise une pièce adverse
ce cavalier rouge et 5
alors la foulée 5 go la menace sans
doute de prendre avec le fou ça
obligerait puis on prend et ensuite
cavalier de cet essai fini puisque je
vais en f5 ce cas elle est magnifique
superbe si jamais attaquable il attaque
un petit peu des 4 et la partie est
parfaitement équilibré ce cavalier
actifs est compensé par le khalife ses
captifs ya et je pense qu'il peut rien
donc il faut prendre un voilà faut
prendre g6 et là les blancs restent dans
une finale avec alors c'est un peu
délicat parce qu'on a le cavalier contre
le fu bon mais on a quand même ce triple
de ce triplé de pions sur cases noires
bon donc on se dit les pièces aux cases
noires avec le full à so foot pourrait
attaquer mais il a pas moyen d'aller
attaquer ceux qui ont des quatre parce
que par quel diagonale il est rien il
peut pas à sept buts sur ses 5 11 7 îles
du trait sur au sein il faudrait
préparer et si c'est possible mais ça
affaiblit aussi ce bon et c'est vrai
très long et on sait on sait même pas si
c'est possible parce qu'on a très bien
contre la colonne f donc on peut jamais
vraiment attaqué la base ici d'autant
qu'en plus elle est attaquée
donc ce foutoir de mon bon malgré la
couleur des pions ce cavalier est actif
puisqu'il attaque à cinq se mobilisent
les noirs et donc après la prison et si
ce n'est sur voila on peut dire que
positionnement les blancs les blancs
sont bien mes biens ne veut pas dire
gagnant bon ceci dit ils ont une bonne
partie à tour f3 c'est un bon coup on
verrouille la colonne f aux menaces très
certainement fait cette tour eiffel sete
parlons tôt à vii et alors là là c'est
fini parce que là là on va se promener
on va venir ans et c'est tout aussi les
noirs répondent par food et 8
on peut attaquer le pion g6 partons g7
et c'est fini la partie est finie c'est
ça va très vite si on laisse se laissent
envahir
voilà donc tour à cette voie la torah
cette voie là contrôle f7 et garde
toujours bien sûr un oeil sur a7 et
pendant que l'autre tour bien sûr
contrôler fuite on pouvait pas mettre
l'autre au tour en 1 h 7 mai sur une rue
touré fuite
eon qui est cheikh et qui gagnent la
torah vite donc il n'a pas le choix
c'est le seul coup en fait cela
voilà roi des rois g2 est maintenant
tous que j'ai huit tranquille à toi sur
les nordistes bon ok c'est sûr que là
moi je fais qu'attendre là j'ai pas de
jets pas une bonne position mais elle
n'est pas non plus mauvaise le sens où
voilà et essaie de trouver comment
passer quoi et c'est vrai que c'est pas
simple or wife de wild 2 pourquoi pas
alors wave 2 peut être activée ce roi
revenir en deux devenir en deux
peut-être pourquoi pour jouer peut-être
les pions aller le roi sans être gêné
par le roi peut-être pour venir jusque 1
c2 bouger ce cavalier m leroy en b3
peut-être mais est-ce qu en b3 et free
quelque chose non c'est pas terrible
donc c'est essayer d'améliorer la
production du roi mais alors ce faisant
bien sûr on coupe temporairement
l'action de ces tours alors c'est pour
ça que là les noirs peuvent jouer touré
fuite alors c'est là qu'on peut se dire
que les blancs pour activer le roi de la
même façon on aurait pu d'abord joué
tour un f2 ça empêche les noirs de
mettre une tour sur f
et maintenant je joue le roi en f1 à
noter que ce fou peut pas venir en c1
attaque et b2 il ya le cavalier donc ya
pas de problème donc tour à f2 ça
empêche la liaison fait ça empêche en
tout cas en échange de tours héros f1
rôle de psy c'est là qu'elle veut aller
donc pourquoi pas mais c'est parce
qu'elle fait donc là ça permet vu que
les tours son cou sont coupés entre
elles ici pouf
voilà on échange la touristique et g8
qui est passive on les change contre la
tour f 3 donc ça c'est un peu délicat ce
qu'elle revient au g2 alors bon vous
voyez que là c'est là qu'on voit que
cette manoeuvre était pas bonne
si vous êtes obligé de revenir ce alors
que la noire pourrait revenir en j'ai
vite c'est la même position ça veut dire
qu'en fait vous n'avez rien fait vous
n'avez pas progressé donc ce n'était pas
un bon coup alors les noirs en échange
tu reprends ton franc et il joue food et
8 tranquille ou alors c'est là que sans
doute mariage raté quelque chose je
pense qu'elle a damé feurs été mieux mon
avis parce que les potentialités de de
jeu était plus grande et et puis bon
même en acceptant cet échange d'un
retour en f2 me semblait mieux dans le
cette idée de vouloir activer le roi
comme ça maintenant je sais pas trop où
aller se voit aussi c'est vrai que c'est
passé un peu ridicule peut-être après la
remise d'activer le cavalier elle aurait
pu essayé d'activer le cavalier et par
ses seins elle n'a pas peur que le fou
échange le cavalier parce que la scala
casef si c'est une case d'invasion pour
les tours qui attaquent 6 qui attaquent
g6 et serait peut-être été difficile
pour les noirs je sais pas il va falloir
analyser en profondeur c'est difficile
car les c1 est ici mais j'essaye
tranquille ou g5 se fout il est
magnifique en asie les défensifs ils
contrôlent à la fois g5 et h5 et à 5
donc ya alors le l'idée des noirs ici
c'est ce qu'on appelle la forteresse
l'idée c'est donc c'est pas d'essayer
d'abord d'activité c'est de venir ben tu
passeras pas ya en jouant j'essaie ya
plus de potentialités devriez le faire
avec les blancs parce que lecavalier
regarder il a pas de casse d'entrée il
va aller où en plus quand on a joué au
fond des buts on libère la tour donc on
m'a sans doute échange de toulon et sète
et après on va pas on rentre mais on
peut pas il n'y a pas de porte d'entrée
en fait le roi noir va venir angers 6 et
puis même si on joue aux cartes rouges
et 4 b on peut soit pousser les pions
soit soit laissée prendre et faire pour
apprendre il n'y a pas de on peut rien
faire il n'a pas montré qu'elles aient
des trois dont g7 où il connaît touche
même pas pour l'instant
g4 au beau fixe on fixe le pion sur la
couleur du four ce qui ce qui rend se
fout totalement passif mais il est
passif mais c'est lui qui tire la
position du hk toyer avec les noirs ici
n'ouvre rien même pas la colonne h donc
y'a qu'une colonne ouverte c'est tout
qu'avait laissé un donc j'évite calais
b3 dont g73 f2 alors ça ça propose une
chance de tours torres est là les chiens
de tours et forcé et après tout reprend
f7 3.973 f 3,3 à 8,3 f2 3f cette partie
nulle voilà il n'y a aucune possibilité
ses pions là sont forme une forteresse
il n'y a pas et rien pour entrer ya pas
de case où le cavalier peut aller il
peut comment il faut et s'il voulait
aller en d6 il faudrait être son c4 soit
1 425 soit en bessin et toutes ces
classes sont contrôlés donc toute
tentative de passe et c'est la perte
sèche en fait y'a rien à faire et le roi
ne peut pas passer non plus tout est
contrôlé c'est puis on contrôle les
cases tout ça et regarder comme ça ça ne
passe pas les pions blancs gêne aussi et
puis en blanc ne permettent pas donc là
on voit bien là et on voit bien le mur
il n'y a aucun trou a pas de possibilité
de faire quoi que ce soit aux contrôles
voilà donc c'est une belle partie
positionnelle que marié losique a sans
doute bien joué peut-être qu'elle aurait
dû jouer dame est fin et puis se court à
f2 aussi qui est quand même à l'air très
maladroit mais y'a peut-être déjà plus
rien à faire peut-être peut-être que
même pas si on fait la manoeuvre que
j'ai donné il n'y a pas grand chose à
faire donc c'est très très bien défendu
de la part des noirs c'est bien joué de
la part des blancs on peut pas dire
qu'elle ait mal joué
c'était comme bien tenté bon c'est un
peu dommage qu'elle joue bien dans la
deuxième moitié du match après être mené
2 0
mais bon il a quand même montré un très
bon niveau de jeu pour l'instant dans
cette deuxième moitié il reste deux
parties elle est menée 2 0
bon je crois qu'on peut dire que c'est
plié ça va se jouer très certainement la
9e du fanal et blanc faudrait vraiment
un truc incroyable pour que vraiment
marié 1 reviennent dans ce championnat
mais pourquoi pas allez on va lui donner
une chance sur mille 0,1 pour cent de
chance ça sera déjà pas mal
voilà donc merci d'avoir suivi un donc
pour cette partie cruciale de ce
championnat du monde donc entre maria
bouzid uk yifan ou la chinoise qui donc
est en passe de reprendre son titre
qu'elle n'a pas vraiment perdu
puisqu'elle s'est pas fait battre en
match et je pense que c'est le seul
critère donc la championne du monde
chinoises qui garde une avance
extrêmement importante sur ses
concurrentes
bon faut encore qu'elle marque le demi
point qui reste pour définitivement
asseoir sa suprématie et l'officialité
du titre voilà merci de m'avoir suivi
sur des modèles tv je donne rendez-vous
donc pour la neuvième partie de ce
championnat du monde féminin 2016
à bientôt au revoir